فسفور يا جماعه
[موسيقى]
فسفور قصف باب المستشفى
يا يا الله قصف باب
المستشفى اسبوع خامس من طوفان الاقصى
اختلطت فيه الدماء على ارض غزه دماء اكثر
من 1500 شهيد من اهالي
القطاع ودماء 34 قتيلا من جيش الاحتلال
بينهم ضابط اعترفت اسرائيل بمقتلهم منذ
بدء التوغل
[موسيقى]
البري توغل لا يزال حبيس خطط واوراق
تبعثرها المقاومه في كل
مره هذه احدى محاولات الاقتحام البري يخرج
اليها رجال القسام من تحت الارض يحلونها
الى كتل من اللهب الله اكبر ولله الحمد
وتقول الفصائل ان اكثر من 33 دبابه ومدرعه
واليه دمرت في الايام الماضيه على عتبات
غزه ومن خلفهم سد فاغشيناهم فهم
نصرون المسافه الصفر وعبوه العمل الفدائي
والمثلث الاحمر ثلاثه مصطلحات تكررت في
الاسبوع المنصرم وباتت رمزا لانتصار اصحاب
الاراده على انصار الاباده مثلما يقول
الفلسطينيون الله اكبر قدم يلا قدم حيث
تمكن مجاهدون بعون الله في ال 48 ساعه
الاخيره من تدمير ما قوامه كتيبه دبابات
للعدو واكثر وعلى الجهه الاخرى يقول جيش
الاحتلال انه قسم قطاع غزه الى شطرين
واصبح يحاصرهم من كل الجهات وبحسب بير
رازو المدير الاكاديمي لمؤسسه البحر
المتوسط للدراسات الاستراتيجيه فان قوات
الاحتلال تخاف من شن هجوم كبير قد يكلفها
الكثير من القتلى وتسعى لقدم المدينه شيئا
فشيئا باستخدام الروبوتات الصغيره
والطائرات المسيره واجهزه الاستشعار
والكلاب
للكشف تحرك الاحتلال على الارض تزامن مع
صف دام تركز هذا الاسبوع على ما تصفها
اسرائيل بالمعابر الامنه لكن احصاءات
رسميه تؤكد ان سكان الجنوب الذي تعده
اسرائيل امنا يشكلون
42% من اجمالي عدد شهداء غزه يا الله
الطفله يا الله على النسوان يا الله على
البنت هنا تتجمع اشلاء اطفال واسرهم كانوا
في طريقهم من شمال غزه الى جنوبها اما
داخل الوحدات السكنيه فاستمر الاحتلال في
القصف باسلوب الاحزمه الناريه موقعا اكثر
من ا عش مجزره ابرزها دير البلح مخيم
المغازي مخيم جباليا شارع الرشيد حي
الزيتون ومحيط مستشفى الشفاء والاربع
مستشفيات تم استهدافها في نفس اللحظه يعني
الناس اللي استشهدت في مستشفى الرنتيسي
كانوا طالعين من عننا واثناء توجههم
لمستشفى الرنتيسي تم صفهم عند باب عند
الاسعاف وعند سيارات
النقل ارتفاع وتيره الهجمات الداميه ياتي
في خضم معضلات تواجه حكومه نتنياهو بدات
تتكشف مع دخول الحرب شهرها الثاني ابرزها
ما كشفت عنه شبكه سي ان ان نقلا عن مصادره
بان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن وكبار
مستشاريه حذروا اسرائيل من تاكل الدعم
الغربي تدريجيا الى درجه انه سيصبح من من
الصعب عليها الاستمرار في تحقيق اهدافها
العسكريه في غزه مع اشتداد الغضب العالمي
من حجم المعاناه الانسانيه المعضله الاخرى
تكمن في هروب اكثر من 230 ال يهودي من
اسرائيل خلال الشهر الاول من عمليه طوفان
الاقصى وفق صحيفه ذا ماركر يعني طابق واحد
مضروب بف 16 فيش فيه يعني اللي موجود جواه
يعني رجل عمره 60 سنه اللي هو ناصر شحاده
وزوجته 60 سنه والاطفال كل ليتهم الباقين
يعني نساء واطفال وفيما يدل على صعوبه
المهمه العسكريه امام القوات الاسرائيليه
اقرت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه بمشاركه
امريكيه غير مسلحه بالتحليق فوق قطاع غزه
للبحث عن الاسرى الاسرائيليين ومن يحملون
جنسيات مزدوجه من المحتجزين لدى حماس وكشف
ايضا عن استقطاب اسرائيل مرتزقه من
اسبانيا وايطاليا ودول اخرى مقابل دفع
اجور مرتفعه تصل الى
3900 يورو اسبوعيا بحسب ما كشف احد
المرتزقه لصحيفه الموندو الاسبانيه اما
المعضله الرابعه فهي العبء الاقتصادي
والاثار المدمره على المديين القريب
والبعيد اذ قفز العجز في ميزانيه اسرائيل
خلال اكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي بنسبه
397 بال على اساس شهري بفعل زياده النفقات
الناتجه عن الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه
وتقول صحيفه كالكلس الاقتصاديه
الاسرائيليه ان تكلفه الحرب التي تخوضها
اسرائيل ستبلغ وفق اقل التوقعات تشاؤما 1
مليار دولار ولعل تاكل القوه الناعمه التي
تدعم اسرائيل واخفاقات البريه هو ما
يدفعها الى تشديد حربها الميدانيه
والنفسيه مثل تلويح وزير تراث عميحاي
الياهو بضرب غزه بقنبله نوويه في تصريح
اثار انتقادات دوليه حاده ثم رفض نتنياهو
ادخال الوقود لمستشفيات غزه ما يعمق ماساه
اكثر من
25000 فلسطيني في حاجه ماسه الى العلاجات
الاوليه وعلى الصعيد الاقليمي حسم خطاب
الامين العام لحزب الله حسن نصر الله
كثيرا من التساؤلات عن احتمال دخول الحزب
الحرب الحاليه وانقسمت الاراء فيه بين من
راى ان الخطاب احتوى خداعا استراتيجيا
لاسرائيل ومن راى انه خيب امال
الفلسطينيين وانصارهم في العالم حسب ما
رصد تقرير لمجله نيوز ويك الامريكيه وفي
مقابل الجمود الرسمي تتسع حركات التضامن
الشعبي مع الفلسطينيين ففي اوروبا
والولايات المتحده خرج 5ه ملايين متضامن
مع غزه وفي مقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك
وقع رؤساء 18 وكاله ومنظمه امميه على
عريضه تطالب بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار ضغوط
كبيره تزيد حرج الاداره الامريكيه التي
باتت اقل حماسا في دعم حليفها
[موسيقى]
الاستراتيجي